- In this video, we're going to talk about
box-and-whisker diagrams.
And these are actually quite common.
Box-and-whisker diagrams.
Especially if you ever
do any stock trading.
If you go to most stock chart providers,
a box-and-whisker diagram is
usually one of the options.
So let's understand how to generate one
and essentially how to read one using
just some data that we have up here.
So the first thing we
want to do is order it
because it we're going to
be finding a lot of medians
when we want to generate
our box-and-whisker diagram.
So let's just order the numbers up here.
So let's see, it looks
like the lowest number here
is 49...so I have that 49.
Then I have another 49 right here,
then I have another 49 right over there,
and then do I have any 50s?
Yes, I have two 50s.
One, two 50s.
I have two 50s...one, two...
Do I have any 51s?
I have one 51 as far as I can tell.
So one 51.
Do I have a 52?
52? One 52.
I have a 52...a 53?
I have one 53...two 53s.
53 and 53, 54...there's one.
54...I don't have any other ones.
55, I don't see one 55 here.
56? I see a 56 right there.
56, and then 57. I have
two--three of them.
One, two, three.
One, two, three 57s.
And I've got a 58.
A 58, a 59...
a 59--let me scroll over a little bit.
And then I have a 67 and I'm done,
I've ordered all of these numbers
and now it's a lot easier
to find the median.
Now, the median as you
may or may not remember
is the middle of these numbers.
So how many total numbers do we have?
We have one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten,
eleven, twelve, thirteen,
fourteen, fifteen,
sixteen, seventeen numbers.
So the middle number, if
you have seventeen numbers,
there's two way to think about it:
however many numbers you
have, we have seventeen,
you add 1 to 17 and you divide by 2
and you count that many spaces from
either the left or the right-hand side
and you will get the middle number.
So this is eighteen divided by 2
which is equaled to 9.
So one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, 53.
Should work from this side as well.
One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, you got 53.
And if you ever have a
situation where it's like
let's say you only have sixteen numbers
and it would be sixteen
plus one divided by 2
you get eight and a half?
That means count eight
spaces and then go halfway
between that number and the
number right after that.
Which we saw that in
a few diagrams before.
But anyway, 53 is the median.
53 right here is the median.
Now, the next thing we want to do
when we want to generate
a box-and-whisker diagram
is figure out the median of the two halves
of the data, notice, if you pick 53,
as kind of dividing line,
half the data is above it,
half the data is below it.
If someone, if, you know,
these are people's ages
and they say they're 53,
they're the 50th percentile.
50 percent of the people
are above their age
50 percent of the people are below it.
This is the middle number.
What we want to do now is find
the middles of the middle.
Or find essentially what is the
25th and the 75th percentile
So what's the number where only one-fourth
of the numbers are less than that?
And there's actually a
little ambiguity here.
So if I want to find the middle of this
left-hand portion right here,
it's debatable whether I want to include
this median right here.
And actually both of those are valid ways
of generating box-and-whisker diagrams.
The typical algorithm,
an algorithm is just
a way, a process for doing things,
is to include this
median in the bottom list
and to include this
median in the top list.
So let's find the median
of this list right here.
So we have one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine numbers.
9 + 1 over 2 is equal to
10 over 2 is equal to 5.
So we count one, two, three, four, five.
Right there, that is the
median of this bottom list.
And we actually call this, right here,
we call this the first quartile,
we call this the 1st.
This number right here
is the 1st Quartile.
And what it does is it separates its--
there's a bunch of ways you could view it.
You could say that all,
that twenty-five percent
or one-fourth, that's where
the word quartile comes from,
you have one-fourth of the
values are below this number.
Or you could say
three-fourths of the values
are above this number.
Now the other way to do a
box-and-whisker diagram,
is you don't include this median,
but I think you would've
gotten the same answer.
But if you did include this median,
you'd have one, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight values...
8 + 1 divided by 2 is 4.5
so you'd go one, two,
three, four and a half.
So you go halfway between these two 50s,
but you would still get 50.
That's the number that's
between a 50 and a 50, is a 50.
So either way our 1st Quartile
number wouldn't be different.
Now, the second quartile is the median.
This is the 2nd Quartile.
I always imagined you have twenty-five,
this is twenty-five
percent of the numbers,
25% or 1/4 of the number,
is the 1st Quartile.
Or it's the first section
fourth of the numbers
and it's upper bound is the 1st Quartile.
Then you have this
one-fourth of the numbers.
This is also 25% of the total numbers
but it's upper bound is the 2nd Quartile
or it's the median, this is from the
25th to the 50th percentile.
And then if we want to go from 50th...
So this is 25th percentile,
this is 50th percentile,
which means that 50% of
the values are below it.
This means 25% of the values are below it.
And then if we want the 75th percentile,
we find the median of
these values over here.
And we'll include this median right there.
So once again we have
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight, nine values.
9 + 1 over 2 is 5.
So you go one, two, three, four, five.
So the median of this higher
half of our data is 57.
So this right here, this
number right there, the 57...
The 57, we call that our 3rd Quartile.
Our 3rd Quartile and it
represents the upper bound
on the section from our 50th percentile
to 75th percentile.
So that's 25% of our numbers there.
You can imagine that's what's
called the 3rd Quartile.
One quartile, two
quartiles, three quartiles,
and of course, the
number 57, you would say
it's in the 75th percentile.
75th percentile,
which means that 75 percent of numbers
where it is the 75th percentile,
75 percent of numbers are below it.
And if you count these, you would see
that's indeed the case.
Anyway, so we've been able to classify
some interesting numbers, here.
Let's actually plot it, now,
using a box-and-whisker diagram.
So what I'm going to do here..
let me draw my x-axis just like that.
It doesn't have to be
horizontal like this,
it could be in any form.
So let's say that this right here is 0.
That's 0, that right there is 100,
halfway between 0 and 100,
I'm just making a scale,
right here is 50, this
right here would be 75.
Now, what I'm doing has nothing--
well I want to include these numbers
but I'm just trying to make a nice scale
to measure by--this is 25.
And so let's draw this data
using a box-and-whisker diagram.
So the median is 53.
So the median is 53, maybe 53
is sitting right about there.
Right, that's right about 53.
That's our median.
Our 1st Quartile is 50,
so 50 is right above--
right there, actually.
Our 3rd Quartile is 57,
so 57 might sit right around here.
I might want to scale this
a little bit differently.
And I'm going to draw a box here.
I'm going to draw a box here.
So this right there, that is 53,
that right there is 57, that's 57,
and that right there is 50.
So what I'm essentially
doing is representing
the middle 50 percent of
the data is in this box.
And this line represents
the actual median.
Now, it's called a box-and-whisker diagram
and I've only drawn a box.
Let me draw the whisker or the whiskers.
The whiskers essentially show us
the entire range of data,
so the lowest data point
is 49, which is right over here.
I should zoom in on this a little bit.
Highest data point is 67, which
is maybe right over there.
So we draw whiskers.
So what a box-and-whisker
diagram is showing us,
it says, okay, most of
the data is sitting inside
of the box, 50 percent of
the data, this 25 percent
and this 25 percent is within this box
but just to get an idea
of the range of the data
it shows whiskers to show the low point
all the way to the high point.
Now let me draw this one a little bit--
Let me zoom in a little
bit because I realized that
this is a little bit all squenched up.
So let me draw it a little bit nicer.
So let me change my scale a little bit.
Let's say that this right here is
let's say that this is...
45, 46, 47, 48, 49, 50,
51, 52, 53, 54, 55, 56,
57, 58, 59, 60, 61, 62,
63, 64, 65, 66, 67, 68
so this right here is 67.
46, 47, 48, 49, 50 that's 50 right there.
So if we use this as our scale,
I think it'll be a little
bit clearer what's going on
with the box-and-whisker diagram.
We have our median, our 2nd Quartile,
our 2nd Quartile is
53, one, two, three, 53
It's right here.
53 is right there.
Our 1st Quartile, the number that is
greater than 25 percent
of the values is 50.
It's 50 right there, that's that.
Let me color code it.
This number, right there,
is this number, right there.
This number, our 3rd Quartile,
the number that is larger than
75 percent of the values is 57.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, it is this value.
Right here, the median,
just to be clear was 53,
that is this value right here.
So now we can draw our box.
We can draw our box.
The box is telling us is
that 50 percent of the values
are between here and
here, between 50 and 57.
And then we draw our whiskers to show
the entire range of the values.
So the highest value here is 67.
The highest value here--
let me do that in another color--is 67.
Is 67, so draw a whisker
that goes all the way to 67.
And then the lowest value here is 49.
So we draw a whisker that goes to 49.
So what you see when you
look at a box-and-whiskers--
so let's say you didn't
even need to see this data,
you just looked at this
box-and-whisker diagram
you'd immediately say,
"Okay, the middle number looks like 53,
"most of the numbers are
50 percent, I should say,
"the numbers are between 50 and 57,
"so most of them are
squenched up over here
"but the entire range
goes all the way to 67
"but it doesn't go too
much below the 50th,
"the inner quartile range,
or the range between
"the 25th and 75th percentile."
So hopefully that gives
you a good overview
and now when you see
these in stock charts--
although in stock charts,
you'll see these verticle
as opposed to horizontal like that--
you'll have a good understanding
of what they're telling you.